you can cancel our eaves as we catch
substituted by cows and snakes own
Council Stanley
that's a Williams has been substituted
by counseling scale and counts the
Wilson non members standing we have
counseled Emily won't concern gray and
paper minutes at the meeting held on 4th
of June 2019 and have picnics assign
those as a correct and accurate record
of that meeting thank you Michael five
declarations of interest it's the dre
I don't mind
the resident
and they could have stolen
okay step down thank you I'm not sure
whether me to clear this or not really
does chair of the MIT so we can all
corridor which oversees adjacent very
much any of us as American Jim I'm not
sure it's appropriate at this stage but
I'm happy to take advice Mike the nation
as
versus amazing 4th of June I will
abstain
item
instead requires the talents take part I
haven't I haven't heard all the
discussion don't do Harriet again you'll
hear it again well okay members you'll
already be aware that we've got a full
agenda tonight some of the items are
bigger items obviously we're going to
take proper decisions and have proper
process but can you please be
considerate that if what you are about
to make is already made there is no need
to repeat anything
as mentioned earlier we've got an
addendum you're all seeing that you're
all aware of that and just just absolute
clarity we've got to the maximum of
about half-past 10:00 tonight to get
through this okay then we're going to
start with item 6 which is 28 and the
quandary of grovyle close chestnut
grille just not grow where it offers
dying this is Francisco take us through
Thank You chairman
exciting to see the junction of chestnut
closed weird self self new road show me
the outlined on this so here the
property is one of three pairs of
detached bungalow as area still the
photograph the moment predominately Bobo
what's important to know why we're on
this plan is the setback distance you'll
see architecture days of recession to
the junction by the architect in initial
Maya building line is much stronger at a
shallower depth on this side further
afield which we'll see in a moment that
you could go to that birds I plan
totally
now our site is usefully delineated by
the red band up on the front garden
there and you'll see his his
predominantly bungalow characters you'll
see who approves but here's this setback
which ever returns an issue before as
purpose of the application tonight if we
can see been afraid place members were
recalled that in
fourteenth of February came before you a
deeper extension and some six meters
which is usually shown in the great
extension on this here we see the
existing floor plan which is really a
nice attractive buying to the design the
applicants thought previously to extend
some six meters from the main wall but
members refused that because of the
impact it was felt in that street scene
and rather too deep to dominate the
applicants listen to what members said
and has come back with a reduced game
1.5 meters less in their sort of four
meters from the play and is a far more
acceptable relationships in their
joining twenties it could be just jumped
to four places
members will see that the layout on the
side concerned did form a reason for
refusing that some members were
concerned about where the parking could
be achieved if you imagine this at a
deeper bed it rather frustrated the use
of upper the fall court relying they are
normally clean on surface the Eponine
the reducing the dead of the applicants
we have achieved some land statement to
the front but also in this area close to
the main door all in all German better
less harsh you can see the emotions on
the five members will see the annoying
carrying through these stretches the
existing character of propulsions
we see the design here this is as
proposed to currently it is set back a
bit severe otherwise an acceptable
design before
and overcoming the critical
recommendations proved okay hm I'd be
happy to propose that we remember go
straight to a vote on this one though
recommendation for approval subject to
the conditions as described as members
in favor of the approval please indicate
disapprove to the face item seven this
is an item that was deferred so this is
land the rear of 37 and 39 down the road
rate
in fact occasions and they have this
application which spent the previous 20
people in Virginia and Constitution has
taken place with yak came because of
location and these storage bins in these
site and here these are the two beauty
and peace and the next I'm going to show
you is plan which is nice meaty and
identified in the yellow the area with
and these restored or the thing of
collective and one things be connected
to attract back and the swords windy and
we come a and dosage of thing and
they've only store this location
particular period of time on the day of
collection and we had for something we
accounts the street scene department and
the waste collection company culture
District Council
have been that they are sexist by the
takeaway from this point it takes on the
plan also a consent of race because to
the construction phase and how equals
with AIDS favorite materials and
shooting to the site and they still
reach and because I've been constructive
method fun not something tight space to
commentators occupation however another
option and has been put forward to us
whereby a machinery and the tools which
would into the site via dismissal reduce
any and obstructions Chiefs like these
and I say notice will be raised from
street scenes apartment an application
to see recommending approval in a cause
of the conditions basically the report
there was
quickly quick on the binge binge passed
a temporary will they not help new
verses cloud-based next project
can you just clarify it for me then the
the extra information you said about the
construction information was that
probably means for an additional
conditional remembers beg your pardon I
slipped up here we've got a speaker on
this one and we should have done that
first to apologize we'll just at this
point I'm failing
very quick pardon
mr. chairman this is what I've got is
say they see a list of points what
we have first issue was how the comments
issued 76 are days working on postage
summary whatever knowledge that's
council objective of the places from an
arrow right away highways the power
going to be a great time unacceptable
Judith narrowness
in previous what the interpretive
accusing the carriages course over
seventy pounds of damage to the world
number 70
unfortunately individuals that reported
the incident did not get a license plate
number Perry said they didn't vote based
on boards of seventh and ninth a Chinese
agent that we've done several occasions
the Highways Department did not appear
to have considered the health and safety
risks of the vehicle breaking down
mechanically emergency or even catching
fire in the right-of-way as it would be
impossible to open the doors due to the
narrowness a lot of drivers passengers
Oh Christmas services to get into it
that's the right-of-way situation with
our team we have actually produced a
survey that we had done to show that the
copying is not as was described the
chairs of our people with the existing
guarantees do smaller forever travel
common colors there is insufficient
clearance returning doesn't comply with
current planning regulations that needs
to look at that produced a a side
picture describe how this looks
they're obviously the red for your corn
extra to back it's pretty tight you
cannot see the mirrors are almost
touching the side so to hell with AoE
from the source in the event of
emergency this is something
the safety this layout is independently
provided and if you want copies I do
have obvious that you cancel
but it does need to take quite clearly
our people is an order problem by now by
the the other saying that we brought
that is boosted responsible for this
market
I personally as not knowing about
parents and I have over the years may
change the surface of the right of way
so who will be responsible for the tank
maintaining it the other thing the
question of the fire somebody occurs the
fire brigade to several minutes ago
okay figure the fire brigade and
promising any paperwork for bin
collection we've discovered not a broad
detail but it still exists now that when
pins are collected and not always
returned to where they come from which
is on the curbside so that could also
cause a blockage in the right-of-way
that's what me you mistake
I'm extremely disappointed that we are
being told we come to accept the
arrangement presentation
concerns about vehicle stop being able
to access the compasses
collectively back to the point where
it's
positions
anyway means
oh yeah if anybody has to be resurfaced
boundaries
okay
you know this is not speak now members
we've got a recommendation for frizzle
printed on the seven point nine through
to 7.11 we've heard the additional
information from officers and
specifically from the discussion last
time the answer about beings and we've
heard clearly that both contractor and
the District Council said the collecting
from the bottom is what we'll want it
what will happen so we now need to move
to vote so those members in favor of the
approval please indicate
those against the approval
and that item is not approved therefore
I must ask one of you to take forward
this item councillor Steptoe they with
the guidance from the offices assist in
this I think the main concern is the
access and is sufficiently wide enough
if there is a problem in the access that
thing I think we can
the excess is not sufficient I think I
do need to get the officer some some
defense in this and that you have got
the officers report in front of you
which is clearly stated that in their
professional opinion independent
professional opinion this is an
acceptable proposal so I understand your
request for some assistance but I I just
need to push you on this occasion a
little bit more to be a bit more precise
the width of the of damaging the chances
of damaging adjacent buildings with if
there was an emergency there was no
particular actus when the baby was
getting in and out and as counsel
understated if they had to weren't able
to get access to the home site then fact
that we blow us back out onto the domain
you're putting forward that motion for
it refused or is anyone happy to second
you on that thank you can I ask if you
feel that you've got sufficient
understanding of the reason to refuse
and before I go I suppose to take note
on this
we do need to be quite clear about
recent reviews although because I just
might highlight they keep policy
promotes to consider is on CD and great
in relation to the college has made part
part of that policy my ex talks about
the availability provision access the
site the provision
that remembers what I think if we could
just repeat the reason refusal
again that's a set up just to move
forward would it help you matter was
referred movies around believe that we
deferred ones around this issue I do not
think it will be fair tonight to defer
to the applicant if we if this item is
deferred once more I think I think it is
only fair to advise that you so care to
really restate the issues are around the
width of the excess if there is an
emergency within the anyway there's no
exit cart exit vehicle damaging to
adjacent properties and if there is an
issue even within the site and after the
bus back
and customization
whoops Thank You mr. chairman which
corner define at the now which was the
question for total patients point
clarification over me thank you I've
heard the basis for the obvious is you
don't if they're not turning maze within
the site but the officer clarify that
again on the same place
in the pool and basically focus on
pollutant objections and I did see where
those ordinary precocity success and
that they attend every costume that
Negro and insight and raise any
objections to use because it existed in
Alameda cysteine and then when they
changed and they all had enough already
because you know the number of concept
of the entrance and exit point Chinese
and they felt that these characters and
disparity
they remember sweet out promotion we
decided not to prove this with no good
emotion for refusal has been provide
faster snap toe and seconded by
Councillor Western on the grounds that
the access essentially is not suitable
for sites so those members have paid
more of the refusal please indicate
those against the refusal that item is
refused
next i 7008 the Cherry Orchard trick
works Cherry Orchard Lane Rockford
there's quite a lot of information in
the adapter for this one
this application likes to this cites the
old Cherry Orchard quick website which
is just east of Cherry Orchard Lane
Cherry Orchard play opposite of site
gira sponsorship cherry about to Jubilee
Country Park to the southern boundary is
slighted joining us the evil Southend
Airport Business Park which is wanted
outlined consent and also have a couple
of reserved matters consent that have
been granted and respected that's like
to to the east of the site it's not a
part of the allocation of which the
slightest apart and I'll come on to that
shortly but this part is under a
different ownership so it is important
to this application before you this
evening to the east of that we then have
the site that is now got the Rugby Club
which is their move from the Everglades
bauxite to the South that's been
relocated here and the normal amount of
the site runs a tributary of the river
right
murmurs the proposal before you tonight
is an outline application with all
matters reserved apart from access to
the site but poses a mixed use scheme
large residential but including
commercial elements the residential
element is 428 dwellings in total a mix
of houses and apartments 65 the point
would be either assisted living
apartments or shelter really in addition
and 93 bed character is composed the
commercial elements on-site or a
combination of a male we can use a tree
restaurant cafe use b1 offices and d1
non-residential such as the day nursery
in part sight southwestern corner there
is already a full planning consent for
240 building on the day nursery at
ground floor and offices above the
development perspective that has
recently commenced the key consideration
in this application is that the
development proposed is not important
we've got to develop a plan and it falls
to the council to consider whether
they're only reasons to run to consent
for this development or not
take you to the eruption expert yet this
is a proposing map that accompanies your
capsules joint error action plan the
science is allocated through employment
use in the joint error action plan this
plan was developed by watchfulness out
memory Council jointly to respond to
opportunities offered by expansion of
South Londoners have an airport the plan
was adopted in which seven 2014 and
identifies designed to support economic
growth in the district to 22:31 the
application site falls within area one
and the red line applications like does
include all of this land this
approximately saving 60 percent
oversight this eastern portion being the
end of the ownership the site in this
plan is okay to be one hottest
development and scientists are benefits
from outline Planning Commission granted
by this council for Biman use grantees
that's their proposal what deliver some
employment opportunities including to
post a 1 a 3 B 1 and B 1 elements as
well as employment opportunities in the
pear phone
but the nature of quantum would not be
set out in this image or terror action
country the proposal would be contrary
to the adopted abundant plan an event or
thought to consider if there are any
material considerations which would
justify departures from the capital
development plan the applicant has
provided abuse for local agents has
referred to in the report and a third of
you are set out in the attendant for
their view that the allocation is not
leaves a gap age would be one of this
development the council are required to
review site allocation is however in
this case the jack looks to develop went
within the allocation up to 23rd right
we're only partway into this time period
is not consider this at this point in
time of conclusion clear image that
there will be no prospect of the site be
developed for being what users intended
this view is supported by the economic
development consultation response and as
of 2014 the application is sure
sufficient and is available to allow
economic growth in the district and the
site lisandro significant pressures to
adoption in the doubt and identify it is
not automatically follow that if the
site considered service to requirements
in the future for b1 use that the site
would be considered suitable for
Berkeley housing that scheme for the
commercial development for instance make
anymore
Avante the neighboring business park in
addition sites not considered to be
sustainable location for housing human
distance to existing residential
settlement site is not imagine walking
distance of existing services and
facilities such as shops and doctors
will take you to the next plan because
there are 4 access point to propose a
part of this outline planning consent
so yeah these show them detail than has
shown on the site plan here so what is
the access point on Cherry Orchard way
and to just the southwestern corner of
the site 3 is the access point that
would have joined directly to the
Southland Business Park own to the south
and 4 is just not with the small Road
Terrace wattages that adjoins site no
higher is what has been received in
response to this application for
previously the high res on 13th quite
the main point of access to be this one
from its south utsire manly roundabout
on Cherry Orchard way utilizing well
this is the main point of access but
also require reference that the post
being to access the site with your
joining business part to the sound
something of favorite in addition
members the situs subject designation by
the Environment Agency in flood zones 1
& 2 if we just take you back to the
location companies
so in roughly
the flood zone to element is a sort of
swathe across their central portion of
the site and it's because of the flood
zone two elements and the proposal for
residential as part of the scheme that
the National Planning policy requires
the local authority to apply the
sequential test to the site the
applicant is not demonstrated that the
sequential test will be passed by
demonstrating that there would be no
other sites within the district at the
logo progress in summary chairman the
Keaton's innovation is that planning
applications must be determined in
accordance with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise the council work with
something more a council to adopt in
joint joint interaction time which
allocates like to be one of the soos and
at this stage the plan process it cannot
be concluded that there is no longer we
need to decide the allocation to such
recommendations revenues of the reasons
I stated today
the usual five minutes then this it is
entirely correct for your officers to
the toilet attention for privacy it is
unusual before that any planning
authority and argue and I'm going to
argue tonight that you should not make a
decision in accordance with development
plan particularly in respect of such a
nature esteem Commodus for attention as
a preliminary to two matters first of
course as was correctly said by the
present your officer this is not an
application so unity lineal with matters
of principle the second matter is that
there is some suggestion in the report
but this is a remote location it isn't a
remote location do they know where the
sightings it's less than one point five
kilometres from Watford station so for
the type of residents who might be
considering on this site as an
operational call you this is not a limit
place it's a few minutes
taxi why
watch it and what station that's just by
way of grounding the conclusion of the
officers reach its paragraph four six of
is that there are no material
considerations which is warranted in
water than the council staff development
plan but I suggested that we didn't
collect the gorge our action plan was
dropped in in 2014 based on earlier data
and analysis the Train should work site
as a p1 allocation is part of a wider
business mark we've been told about that
of course but it's the applicants case
of office development is most unlikely
to come formed you know that no of his
development has taken place on the
business area location no our so far as
is known is any contemplated in what
area if there was any such indication
would have been told about it by now
there is a lack of demand that's simply
a fact we say the market value of
movement or our office space in this
area which to blow to justify
development developers will not spend
our more on building a department that
it's going to be worth in the
marketplace but appointment is made by
both fairs in the crooks
now the basis of our view as as I've
indicated is we have to up today two
systems not one to up to date
assessments by leading the mercial
property engines in the area as some
crooks of the 13th of March of this year
and Grady the 24th of June 2019 now you
have the advantage in the supplementary
material and he addendum of the very
report perhaps I could just draw your
attention to page three of your addendum
the top of the page which is the end
result
I didn't eat something infinitely
vendôme and it's that first paragraph in
our opinion and the last paragraph
taking that into consideration of
eyespace emphasis so having having that
in mind to say that as the officers
contend that there is no clear evidence
to indicate that there is no demand for
the allocation employment at the site is
simply wrong officers suggest in
paragraph 4 to 13 sorry 3 that 312 312
of the report that you can deal with
these contentions he's up to
actions by the agents by the specialists
agents part reference to the 2017
economic needs assessment an immediate
sucessfully obviously is not because
it's 2017 that not the gains assessment
of the current market just a minute ago
there is in effect no response to the
clear opinions given by r some crooks
and then now my second point is that
this is for a specialist retirement
village you have the content it's been
explained to you by the officer it is
not sustained the residential scene
there is ample evidence to justify and
policy to support such specialist
provision in principle there was a
pressing need and if it it wasn't
already obvious that there was a
pressing need yesterday and 26th of June
government published new planning
practice guidance with regard to the
need to provide housing for older people
and it's indicated in there that the
need to provide housing for older people
is critical and as far as we needed to
do that so there are two points it was
an opportunity it's worth considering
this opportunity
any of our visiting members we should
have baked on this one okay that's the
step time thanks Jim
I hope concerned that as our speaker is
already in t mentioned there that there
is a new document new guidance that has
been issued by central government in the
last few days I've assumed that officers
have not had the opportunity to be able
to look at this particular application
exactly in my thought those took my mind
on that when I take advice and what is
here as to whether the matter should be
deferred for officers to be able to take
those take the opportunity to take that
guidance into account
initially the council mr. nations make
your point Mario Kassar scepter is happy
or do you want to continue counselor
said could I have an answer to the
question just so many things not go
ahead thank you this is a complex and
comprehensive application we have in
this district a wide range of need the
different types of property is demands
every sort of agree with the applicant
there is the demand for this tonic
however I have concerns about the
location that is proposed for this
development and put some rough notes
here firstly we have an area plan their
plan that goes up to 2030
I think it is premature to assume that
they've demand of being one use will not
be there in that time span I don't think
we're far enough into our area plan our
district planning to assume that it's
obviously a matter of opinion but that
is my opinion the speaker also states
that and here I have a contradiction
speaker states that the situation was
not the area is not remote but their
very own argument says it is remote
which is a contradiction in itself the
item that he referred to on page three
of the addendum so the current poor
connectivity to the site the nearest
station of rockford and the lack of
on-site facility
with bergamot deterg-- manfully obvious
center but if that's the case it would
also determine the land for residential
use and there is concern over there but
for residential use
you need more public transport than you
do for office use not less it also says
there's a poor connectivity in that
provision which as I say that there is a
problem there the other area that raises
concern Essex County Council raised
concern during the flood risk assessment
and then a world documented in their
report and not something else
intimate richard overlooked and last but
not least if we were to apply this for
houses I would expect there to be a
consideration for the more social
housing as per our policy
regardless of the fact that this is
found 50 priors which I understand
restricts it somewhat we still have a
need for affordable housing for that
category of resident as well and our
policies for 35% I don't see that
mentioned at all or any consideration
given to that so unbalanced I have heard
no material considerations to deliver
from our dr. clay which goes to 2013 we
certainly support the emphasis report
which i think is very hot yes
okay that's a sure
Clippy chair I've got cancer one sector
regarding and deferring it my concern is
that we haven't heard the Essex County
Council highways reporting so we are
actually missing reports and I don't
think we can make any decision on any
application if we haven't so it's true
that given that the planning process
guidance was revised and issued
yesterday officers have read it and it
wouldn't go to the heart of reasons that
we don't want so it wouldn't I don't
think have any bearing on the reason for
refusal that relates to the applications
proposed in content to the adopted one
in the plan and eject the allocation
recite for employment use however they
said that given the advisor position
yesterday we have very detailed
consideration it might affect one of
these
so in terms of surface so suits in a
second train eh they have no objection
in principle
so in principle they're happy that if
the scheme work group and we could
acceptable strange speed it would work
II the flooding issue this reason
refusal is more than in principle one
because the MPP Act requires to do what
we call sequential testing because part
of the sites in from zone 2 and it's the
residential element that it triggers us
to look to make sure that there were no
other sites that could to take the
containment whether private or in the
NASA field waste in the district and so
that
good posture yet again the alignment
issue in the PPG would have no effect on
the relation to that anyone support you
in your I just like to say a few words
on this one before we go to that vote on
I'm not in favor of deferring at this
point I've read the the five reasons for
refusal that the officers have put
forward and I think they clearly
explained in their presentation I think
they are they're there to do with our
core strategy our core strategy wasn't a
document that was decided on overnight
it was it was many many years work and
of course it's not fixed in stone
revolution takes place in the in the
planning environment and clearly there's
a little bit of evolution taking place
in the past few days but we're talking
about the principle of housing in this
location I'm not averse to the type of
development that is presented here but
it's the location councillor Mason has
pointed out about the connectivity I
just don't feel that location is
appropriate for residential housing
we've got a principle here about the 50
parks but once the principle of
residential in in that location is
established then there is chance for
what for change there I have a great
deal of confidence in economic
development in Rockford District Council
with the work that this council and
Southend
are doing based around the job at all
that's non there and I do think that the
work around that area can be described
as some something of a success at this
point in time some of the areas that are
mentioned
the independent reports I think are
quite quite different in their in their
nature so at this point in time because
we're talking about the principle I feel
that the strength of the the arguments
that are put forward through the
conditions of recruit approval
remembering that the core strategy had
every aspect of it tried and tested I'm
not going to say this is a speculative
application clearly not it's a it's a
full application when I I don't think it
fits within the the spirit of the core
strategy on what we're trying to achieve
so on that basis I wouldn't support a
deferment at this point first the
developments has been made and it's been
seconded then one I else want to speak
towards the deferment before we go to a
boat right okay members if you're in
favor of a deferment please indicate if
you're against
this item is going to be deferred and
specifically the items around the
evolution of planning policy and what
we're looking to and then comes the
hardware parts
I do 9 again this information on the
addendum Mitchell inspired me to leave
our arterial road rain
why you're 26 weeks in the West and the
science no and to the teachers and
programs like this to show you
to the west and pays164 planning
commission whereby all matters such as
axe
ow layout and appearance must be
considered the circle of peace
base to to the waist like I said it's a
larger part of the psyche and see
outline content only there which it must
be noted that the master plan shows land
site please make way - only in TTIP and
changed and how the face could be all
for it and the applications is not
included gypsum traveler site allocated
to the south western corner outlined in
blue
however this dissent below access and to
Nepal the site and therefore this
development pose does not prevent an
application point for you can keep the
protein synthetic design
so late - for phase one we're both like
sedating at all matters such as access
plan escape from scale layout and
appearance makes we consider this lights
on in strokes 11 project relation and
show you two beauties one of those who
sees the boundary at one a day since the
boundary of face - and car parking later
infinity runing and an element of
compartment and way back to the entrance
where that when I've seen proposed laid
out for such but it is the age of the
site and further nine taken around the
southern window into the elevation and
the prelude into this hub sites and we
are considering the screwed up as we
need to go get to point one and they've
been amazing to make sake do means and
the pro foods this part of the site
reach up to 30 meters high to reach
blazingly proposed in the corners and
and the facade is broken up air leaks
coyote wound and a range of colors from
some visual interest the buildings and
industrial scale and nature and
unacceptable given the uses account and
I take you back to the site plan and it
posts the access and gave one to seven
and so it promotes exercise idea of the
a 24 by travelpod if I rotate we can see
one two four five to eight so cars truck
in society exercise obstacle team 7up be
able to put five and by media road and
to the junction this access road and
third one as well as Phase two and so
that access and also so traffic exiting
the science so in and out and Junction
all be a belief in the site would have
to exit site traveling northbound long
be a one two four five and it's the
junction was designed in constipation
assistance of counsel and Highways
Authority and they are satisfied that
excess would be a perfect life and
scouts that need development and
therefore exactly how to be ready
doesn't include a policy in the
allocation plan of was confronting and
only plan and
but they have been recommending subjects
the conditions outlined beautiful okay
well non-members wish to speak on this
one that's the very person
the last question Shakira dance to
inasmuch as the site itself with three
pieces of Hydra pages
like this
and
I'm just wondering if this is a proof
yeah that's a little concerned
thanks Joe and I was just gonna make a
couple points actually adjusted one
workable counsel appraised estate from
the informations no pleasing the
consulate of psychic center I've
recently acted but counselor drag myself
being broadcast both areas they sent
Castle Road I've recently a conversation
with here door from the cat accounts
regarding that's a short video that's a
few days ago with workers going to
recommence with regards the relocation
of that site because they do that and so
that does need to be broaden my
knowledge respectfully suggest and I'd
like to say actually I'm also beta this
I think it'll do as developers
opportunity because in principle I have
no objection to my two points I'd like
to make the first off I don't think they
probably get an answer to this and the
gypsy traveller sites and allocation bit
of the Atlantis site and all we will
have week the sitter's st. it's about we
have an eclipse in German sausage
district and we didn't panic and said
for this you develop that as well if not
was that certainly can do it should be
protected we're not looking at it I
would suggest and the second point I'd
like to make is walk around safety and
road safety and what if the officers
could give me some assurances that the
highways the bomb at the county council
was focusing about this because that
stretch of the eight or four to five
international speaker which means the
vehicles tracking on their training more
than environment
and miss the build exiting that site
I'm gonna have to get to speed up to 60
miles an hour plus before they draw in
lane one of my territory so that exit
moment has to be equal to the set to
announce it to a dual carriageway which
is consumers have been given
consideration if not it needs to be or
if not slightly tucked and ugly wrex
multiple question if not Kathy highways
are being asked about the reduction of
speed which would be beneficial for two
reasons first of all with equal increase
website users the traffic will be coming
more slowly
and secondly I do understand the whole
of the one through seven from the
culture world war deception in America
tomorrow no privacy so has that been
given consideration
Absalom make
they're gonna love this we're saying no
it's not just make some points easy way
of the education and it's a parkland
sight while say are aware and that's a
cool on finding owner of life it's not
something for us to pressure us such do
that but they are aware that that is
medication and that doesn't important at
some time and they wear everything
needed district or educational site and
with regard to highways it has
everything it didn't work regarding is
access and it was also being preparation
such and development to get the patients
and they will look at very safety and
speaking it's may will be reduced in the
area much you know understand like as if
it is in for an hour and possibly that's
I'm signing that agreement ends up
considering this application but
highways are aware of that and
that has been discussed between the
benefits and Expensify way and I said
they were in completely in terms of
design in that Junction and those 3d
rates and they don't raise any
objections it's that they the points
very funny and they are aware of that
ourselves
the only one consultation yeah I mean
this this I have been marked it on the
way interest has information that way
about that that's something that could
potentially happen and take place within
face to face to these is indicative if
we just look at the Beckman
so whether the development of a button
volume whether they compactly to
accommodate that we being the site they
may well do and but this much almost
don't know okay yeah okay
now sorry that's
just yet you just got one more month
right moving on to members had cancer
step toe take Jim just for ask one
question to ask with regards to he exit
onto the 12:45 day that's just before
the rally which is roughly whether you
were planning their words upside down
just the other side of the railway
bridge is where the proposed Junction
will sit well coming from the i-130 will
feed into the twelve will strike which
will be controlled by traffic lights so
that section of road in time become a
far more patrol boat in terms of speed
my questions if I'm a chair around the
site as it is currently I think most
members here will be aware of what's
been going on for that site over many
years and what about me being dumped on
there raised my concern I'm concerned as
to how and I've not seen in the report
that the site needs to be clear there's
a lot of waste that's being dumped on
that side we don't know what it is it
could be anything in that specialist
waddle you know those tires burnt out of
course
that how is that going to be monitors
how is that going to be controlled and
as part of that process where would it
then be disposed that leads me on also
as well with regards to the wildlife
wildlife that will be coming from there
it's a fairly isolated site for having
roads on 20 sides and a railway line
down the other so the wildlife there
will be fairly contained but with the
prevent contamination that is on the
site if things are poor the crested
newts if there's any there are relocate
ease will there be any issues in those
critters or was the problems with the
area's they then move to with the
diseases they may want to carry there
was that going to be confirmed also as
well the water runoff to be a concern
with regards of what has been dumped on
the site that's obviously going to run
into the natural water courses around
the area again how will that be
monitored because of the content
then to avoid repetition we probably
gone straight to the heart of most of
the concerns about this and some
colleagues but that condition has been
amended
do we assume that your rate would be
don't require that condition that's page
9.8 going through out a nine point nine
that's quite a big condition
should there be a big transportation
let's go back so just to clarify the
full four I question you sir what - I
can be quite happy when I lived with
regards to the removal of the they are
still about how we are going to control
where the things up the assessment that
they give you you will know where that
that watch thing means a very standard
condition of this comprehensive though
it's used on a lot of sites some perhaps
with less contamination in this one but
parts of it talks about so detailed site
investigation means actually sampling
and then you know there's a results come
back and then the remediation speed has
to be sent out so that in detail will
explain how they intend to deal with any
combination as you find other side so we
will be expecting that to be dealt with
depending on the time
so they include feeling going to
struggle yep members we've got a
detailed report we've got a area of land
for commercial development which meets
with our strategic plan we clearly see
that we're talking about the detail
phase one and an outline for Phase two
and you just put up phase two just
remind members so that's what you see on
the screen now
just like my plan again the detailed
area that were talking to and then the
principal we could see that that still
retains clear access for the land that
we've allocated to Gibson travel aside
the points that members have made about
wanting to see that gypsum travel of do
that site develop as the gypsum travel
aside rather than anything else is quite
well made and I'm quite sure the
developer here at afternoon will
understand the will of the council to
see that happen why whatever whatever
means and whether their learning happens
with that is it is a question outside of
that this meeting but we have a
recommendation for approval printed on
knowing point well with a series of
conditions that go right away
so nine twelve we've taken note of the
information in the addendum and mention
of of site variations to the conditions
so members those in favor of the
approval please indicate thank you very
much
this is all sort of unusual shape so the
red line actually follows the prose part
of the postcentral spyro and then it
also includes an area here is to treat
your landscaping in ODIs skirts around
pros attenuation problems and then comes
down to the south and follows the line
of the proposed road so this application
seat reserved must consent for part of
the central spine road in this central
location within the London Road site the
northern section of this spine road is a
continuation of that northern section
and that normal section already benefit
from full planning consent the road will
be some six point seven meters wide with
the landscape in swales to either side
both stops will be located say one
adjacent or close to the playground that
is just east of the site and then one
further further south adjacent to what
will be a phase of residential
development at the site access then
several accesses lead off so one here
already not there the six point of
access it will lead off the spine going
that's proposed into these residential
parcels in relation to which you will
see the zone matters application is
coming forward in due course the
proposal also includes a pumping station
here just north of the M so the service
water attenuation pond which is here an
electricity substation positions there
in part of the strategic landscape thing
the location of the pumping station and
pond are considered acceptable drainage
details relating to the product and
phases two and three will be dealt with
by condition imposed on the original
outline planning consent so it's not the
drainage detail information to this pond
we're looking at and this evening it's
more just the principle of why the
problems always going on the site a lot
of information on this planet could zoom
into the top sort of corner so this is
the elevations that's fine thanks this
is the elevation of their electricity
substation so it's two point five meters
in height approximately there is an
indicative Lea showing an extra meter
and so that made me necessary and it's
three square meters in a footprint then
to the compound for the pumping station
so the compensation isn't building as
such as the compound it's quite large
it's 8 liters by 12 12 meters thereby
power8 and it contains all the equipment
related to the pumping station within it
chairman the recommendation is for
approval and subject to the conditions
are sent out in the report in a further
two conditions one standard condition
related to the approved plans just for
clarity and the second additional
condition of relating to details of
boundary treatment to the pumping
station so the enclosure fencing that
would be around that and also the
external facing material substation this
pumping station actually is one of this
I'm going to replace one that was
proposed but these ones leave essential
endplates wazniak somewhere here that's
already one reserved matters consents
which instead of putting it there
various reasons the applicant proposed
it to be in this position here and we
say that this there's no harm caused by
that we can control the landscaping
surrounding it which will operate
somewhat from be too apparent in the
landscaped area and also will control
the external materials so the
recommendation subjects those two
conditions including our members wish to
say anything on this one visit this one
on the number of times and there's a
basin
to maneuver a second that you okay
members across my I feel will go
straight to the approval for see
adjustment to the conditions as outlined
to the offices so those members in favor
off the approval please indicate to
actually knowing the sleep through item
11 is softer woods main road Hockley
[Music]
advertising world today that will take
place on this application following on
from these expectations that the agent
of the bottom panel measures or makes is
finally made due to its super nature and
if not considered to have any effect on
the character and appearance and streets
ain't no different elusive building and
all carpet Jason since light and it has
been recommended a third condition
should be added and icicle has me to
find temporary and the further condition
had been recommended to allow temperate
to to be displayed that period 28 days
or no more than two occasions in
anything the year and if that patient
has been recommending approval subjects
the conditions outlined in report as
well as the sadistic condition
I don't wish to dub this supplication
down members but it's just a violent
plan that it's got very limited lifespan
because it has a date on it cows the
Western second that ok discussion but
everyone fully aware of what we're
working for those homes in favor of the
approval please thank you that's
approved just a formality
[Music]
I remember this one is an application
referred from the weekly list thousand
twelve thirty degrees Woodrow
Rayleigh mr strannix future this
application is to the site of the vacant
for VAR retail unit located on the north
side of East Road redemption Webster's
the members committee with Riley it's
the bacon former car price shop I
understand the bacon some time you see
the building as we say three stories
Mason it's above the site you know the
traditional two-story flat as it were
above about the shop architectural II of
its time 1950s dominant construction
what interests us is the the shop front
teeth up here is very limited proposed
works just recovering the aluminium
paneling that you can see the yet
reglazing pants and the lower us the
windows and doors would have a frosted
violent applied so they have a limit
visibility while we're on this photo a
couple of vents you'll see them or
opposed to the side view if we could
jump to the location
like if we could see that the
floorplanner top there is mercy it's an
unusual shape there's an access to the
rear courtyard to behind the premises
Webster's ways along here this is the
stairwell on the end which this way some
members to be familiar with that gives
access up to the Mason is above and the
applicant is showing control over these
two car parking spaces here is the back
entrance to benefits the calf next door
which adjoins the unit use propose to a
safety report is for a micro pub and in
planning terms that's what we call it
use class pay for whereas cafes and
restaurants that use Class A through the
point being that your radius and center
action area plan looks to avoid
clustering of the same uses and because
these are not a one uses they are still
two different use classes in planning so
it doesn't amount to a cluster one is a
pub type use the adjoining unit would be
a three there is though a for one unit
away which is Jojo
whispers they don't because the - don't
touch because they're separated by the
Bentley's cap and they don't
Buster you might help them as if we jump
back to the location properly there are
two main principle concerns with this
there is the use that the site is not
within the conservation area
conservation area boundary comes around
this but it is within the town center
and it is within your second to shop
advantage which argues that non retail
uses should be located in this part of
the town and then this familiar with
this variety you'll see that there's a
range of eighty-three somebody for uses
in here also one tucked away outside the
street in between the non retail uses
there are some reason is it's going to
the carpets name one occupying the big
units so I'm putting across is a mix of
uses in this location appropriate to the
secondary frontage member will see that
from the extensive reply to consultation
from the council's economic development
team but the proposal being and is
considered to further diversity by the
interaction of writing as a center
because it offers specialist drinks an
experience that they argue that would
draw people in deliberately to have a
social event and evening they're
sampling those foodstuffs not to be
confused with traditional pubs and
activities that are associated with a
satisfying new provision and this 18
vacant premises or a contribution to
projected future denied to the Year 2034
or additional food outlets so you can
see that our colleagues in economic
development support and it was so this
application is tiny in that it comes to
you whilst there is a five-year lovely
new shop openings the unit itself been
vacant for a period of time and
therefore these factors why you were
totally against that members will see
that there's been four letters of
support they're not in immediate
vicinity of the site but you'll see that
there are five letters in a petition of
number 13 addresses together before
additional Weber lectures on the
attendant expressed objections now the
predominance of these are people in open
court
we live up in those major Nets I pointed
to you in the photograph and those
people that you'll see from the
representation they made and concerned
the social community issue we have
arisen through the nighttime economy
particularly citing that one of them
comes near nearby now the applicant
state that micro cups have a reputation
for largely being trouble-free
they attract a clientele that is
unlikely
of course travel but you'll see from the
opposites reports if you Grunk
commission for a park particular micro
park it could under the use classes
order changing use to something bike JJ
whispers or something because when you
often as members have seen I think it's
changeable in grant permission for a
particular user in mind by default you
can get a different cuisine or whatever
as long as it's in the same news
so last members to be mindful of that
but you will see that the officers
report it doesn't seek to control the
use within the news parties order and
you'll see that the officers report
doesn't seek we control the use like
ours the applicant here has stated that
they would operate 11:00 a.m. to
midnight Monday to Saturday 12:00 midday
to 11 something to make compton it's
been history for this area rainy town
since Oakland the licensing regime
conflicts with in positions you might
make as a committee on the Planning
Commission so officers are deliberately
avoided conditioning hours because that
really is the job for the licensing
legislation the members will appreciate
that if you put ours on a planning
meetings there's a process to do with
the enforcement but if it's not so much
just about the hours of the news that it
is about the running of the premises etc
the the activities and the callings of
police things like that that I think
keep the public concern I believe and
I'm not licensed an expert but I believe
a licensee can lose their license or
habits are reviewed with those things
with the planning permission once
planning permission is granted you would
only have to have the control powers
should they reach the out so obviously
they've come to me that the controls
that probably best deal with behavioral
issues and anti-social behavior that is
inconsistent
that's the remake that the licensing
regime now with those issues members
will see that in reply to consultation
the council's environmental health team
have made a number of recommendations
which draft conditions three and four we
seek that the building is insulated
against the egress of the noise rating
inside the premises that will be done
and the consideration of the detailed
equipment opens the vents except for the
noise vibrator so the recommendation is
subject to the conditions set out yeah
absolutely
when you refer this I was doing nothing
but will will come to you probably put a
speaker on this one which is yeah mr.
Sackett occupant wallet
five minutes mr. chairmembers good
evening it's actually me that life is
changing fuses the application but no
antecedent positive reports of the
planning of the regeneration drupal's
demonstrated complete understanding of
what I'm trying to achieve it's
understandable that the residents of all
four cold would have concerns about a
new drinking establishment however I
think it's unrealistic to compare the
proposed microphone with JJ whispers
which is essentially a late-night
cocktail bar nightclub as DJs caters for
younger customers I'm sure their
customers would have little interested
in visiting microphone any more than the
typical micro customers on the night I
consider myself to be a typical micro
customer
proposed smoking errors beneath the
concrete canopy which I believe is
within the boundary of the property the
area was used by other businesses in the
block a customer seating and was used
for over 20 years
by the previous tenant to display mr.
Sol the government has done a great deal
to encourage the craft and Kasmir
industry with the introduction of a
small bruise relief and relaxation of
the pending thus enabling more small
drinking establishments toilet because
of the dominant position of the large
breweries and popgoes in the
distribution chain micro pubs are
extremely important to local breweries
even though all the pubs in rainy town
centre have real offerings
none of them are from the local brewery
property casks would go a long way to
rectify the situation
thank you
that's a welcome thank you Jim and I'm
here representing the resident self of
course that's the reason why I put those
applications because the residents of
all the court contacted me I wish to
record the residents objections that are
trying to poison initially the first
objection is to change of use the
building itself was built with flax
above as mr. strains has said around
about 1950s or so when the shots from
pathology Haven use the noise generated
for such purposes Smith and not
something political is annoying to the
residents about since then 100 in this
one ability to change its use by blank
anonymous graduate whispers the noise
which is a generation this building has
caused constant upset and annoys an
annoyance the residents about one
business I spoke with as the management
of catering this was on a first main
terms there have been a number of public
or residence at premises to where police
have been called but she is constantly
texting him and phoning the kind of joke
asana turn music down the titleist in
front of you you can see the flats above
the flat immediately above and that
corner is occupied by a young lady who
were fortunate actually the
superintendent they were at since the
scene but one of them whether
petitioners birthday today so they've
left one of the many things here is the
occupants that classify as two young
children the noise from the bar or pub
will spill out onto the street and those
soundproofing the thought will protect
the residents for the noise the music or
the noise in the customers and I would
ask each member here would you want to
live above a licensed premises because I
certainly would not
once the use has been changed from Avon
use there is no restriction as mr.
strangdour rightly said on somebody else
coming along an eighteen-month society
is that if Miss Martin part sadly
doesn't survive I'm putting a normal
Isis premises in its place there is no
restriction in the current application
this applicant of changing his business
to a different supper dream there
attracting different condemned cell once
this has changed it is changed and the
piece of the message of God has gone to
good if the proposal was simply self
beard and not for the consumption on
premises then there will be no objection
to this ie for retail use and therefore
that we no need for the change of use
either the officer has cited in his
report or her reports a number of bars
as good examples of Parramatta pub can
work one of these bars society is West
rose attack it is a variety closing
times or visit we can see close at 11:00
p.m. on the holy post at ninth year
another micro publish I researched is in
battle Street and called one green
bottle the opening hours for this are
11:30 a.m. to 6:00 p.m. daily it closes
that is where that's without residence
about it restaurant seats pop-up it does
not close past 6:00 p.m. this part
proposing to open from 11:00 a.m. until
midnight on Saturdays and midday to
11:00 p.m. on Sundays and bank holidays
so to equate it to an almighty possible
hours custody's not realistic the plan
also mentions the soybeans external area
you just come on to the floor plan thank
you just scroll down yeah we'll see
that's not that picture that's it thank
you the proposal has a has a standing
area outside the premises there are no
measurements or price was to how big
this area will be in fact it states that
it is something which we decided after
the planning process has been agreed I
would respectfully suggest that submit
this is fundamentally wrong this should
be part and an important part of the
planning process and must be included
within the consideration as such I
submit this application incomplete and
should not yet be adjudicated or equally
there was guy who sets out a pilot
department for transport in the manual
for streets about the size of foot ways
paragraph six point three point two two
states there is no maximum width
place the lightly used streets such as
those pure to residential function the
minim obstructed weak from the textual
should be generally be two meters
additional width should be considered
between the foot way and a heavily used
carat weight or adjacent to gathering
places such as schools of shots which of
course this area is he then goes on to
say foot way witness can be vary between
different streets to take a
counter-petition volumes and composition
streets where people walk in groups on
this scores of shops for example the
wider foot ways the areas of high
pedestrian flow the quality of work
experience can deteriorate it says the
pedestrian congestion through
insufficient capacity should be avoided
this is inconvenient it may encourage
people to step into the carriageway you
just go back to the first part with this
site I firstly attended this site and
spend some time there monitoring the
pedestrian traffic they're not taking
measurements to the existing pavements
this was at about 11 a.m. on a weekday
morning and trying to get an average
transpositions at best looking at the
front of the building to the right on
front door there is a corner there are
existing brass studs on the pavement
which I understand was that directed on
but I understand you know maximum
distance of shopkeeper come it can come
out from the building life for this
starts the playlet edges 1.9 meters
which is less than the minimum guidance
for residential streets in the home from
the mod manual guidance and clearly a
lot less that they would recommend for a
road the distance of this sort that
produced that distance reduces
dramatically and it probably isn't
showing you whether this photograph but
members who know this area will know
that reduces dramatically as you
approach the zebra crossing during
period of time miles and sites I watched
a lot of people walking backwards and
force towards vegetables pasta shop they
all needed to use the area under that
canopy they all needed to use the area
within the confines of those studs to
prevent themselves from going on the
road because of the amounts of refer to
the reserve to bollards signs pollution
victims and the residents
added to that Rosetta Cross news at
bottleneck whilst pedestrians wait for
cars to stop and give wires with other
people
to get past each other as it is this is
this external plank pose in the external
area that planned earlier Cespedes
problem
the advocate mentions that they supposed
to use the same area used by the
previous shopkeeper the previous
occupant had baskets and plastic boxes
outside which lost the mud sects were
unable to wander off on their own
therefore it remains contained it is
unlikely that any person standing
outside drinking will remain in one
place in the Oh spills the paper will
have a dramatic effect on the safety
pedestrians who are passing are they
opposed to permit that the external area
cannot be incorporated mr. proposal
either in conclusion German I
respectfully submit that this proposal
is incomplete and it is flawed it takes
no account of the needs of the residents
above that is evidenced in the opening
hours which are all suggested entirely
unacceptable it is not in the right
location due to the residential
properties which are above it and it's
positioned far too close to the zebra
crossing or West's way must be to be
safe for pedestrian traffic passing each
other therefore ask members to reject
this proposal on the basis that the
change abuse cannot be agreed in this
location because the points that are
great picture cuts the drain Thank You
counsel
in surgery regards to the narrow way
it's already narrow and it can be
distressing people using area
so I do Shady's concern with regards to
the narrowing of that payment
maglin okay fungus then because the mr.
face in your indicated Thank You mr.
chairman I read this was quite
interesting on this report on our own I
understand the concerns and it's
interesting as well to see that ready
Town Council in a mixed response to the
application which I think explains the
dilemma we have heard here the main
concerns around this both relate to the
impact on neighboring properties firstly
the location of smoke on the forecourt
as Khosla Wilson has demonstrated which
could be detrimental to both residence
of the properties above and passers-by
especially with the precision of the
proximity to the pedestrian crossing if
you look at this plan can I however the
sort of thing thank you it looks amazing
they're composing to put some sort of
seating or stores along webster's way
site is that correct
you know chairman if I might I
understand these are the high schools
that you spend right so that
we could go back to the location place
both of the picture of a toboggan
I could hear those concerns I think the
existing pavement we can't do anything
about it it's not our pavement pavement
may be narrow but this isn't a planning
application to build it's a planning
application for a change of use and the
building is in existence I would suggest
that with the proposed that with the
smoking element and the concern of the
narrowness there but no absolute smoking
area is allowed along that frankish and
I think that's a Webster's way is it not
these this Webster's way is down here
this is the junction of each row so the
building has an angle on to the crossing
of the junction that is fairly at least
road frontage the building goes round
the corner but I take the point that the
canopy and these stats delineate a
forecourt
which any user would be entitled to you
so when you go back to the manual for
Strings it may be that it doesn't comply
now the for the pavement I mean Dave
Bowman Street but obviously when this
was laid out whenever it was the highway
authority of did you know the expense of
the highway with the stunts I think
that's a a project they did some time
ago and there were lots of confusions
without fresco dining at all and
everything else so they've marked the
limits of the highway so the applicant
is sold as a shop again for instance
somebody could display produce and
things outside it is outside the sky
narrowing the pavement and you have no
control but I take the point that the
activity of drinking with people go
outside operator smoking they do move
around
it causes that problem it's an
interesting point thankfully suspect
what my suggestion is that we had a deal
but if we have my need to approve this
and I think on planning terms we have to
that we add additional condition that
that agonal decide is not used as a
smoking area only the side the straight
side and I'm sure the obvious is can put
that more clearly than I can but
certainly that that is a concern and
that if that's not used why people
sitting or standing and smoking it will
alleviate to some extent in difficulties
that are foreseen the quality of Yolanda
Nativity is experienced by noise
disturbance created by nearby
establishments is distressing to here
and I've got every simple thing with the
residence but we have a situation when
this is a planning application not some
licensing application we cannot here
prejudge the intuitive effect of the
hours requested
indeed the as requested or suggested by
the applicant in his application unless
there were no powers that are already
exist but when there JJ whispers the
there will be additional noise from
egress and start leaving but that said
this is a planning application and on
planning terms for the change abuse I do
not support the officers recommendation
with the additional description on the
outside smoking and the issues with
noise and disturbance which we've heard
we should be taken on board by the
licensing committee and I'm sure they
will have a full report and deal with
that other protections persist so I
would move for approval subject that
additional condition makes it counselor
so I'll just run this on the smoker
project plans you were showing you said
it was an area to smoke which at the
front that's what I was just wanted to
check usage it's up there smoking area
under canopy no that is in the front
it's in it not on the side there's two
stores on this
no that's hanging so I'm on the
right-hand side which is smoking area
covering many members are righty
the applicant a plan to say these stalls
would be like a smoking area and I take
the point that members are concerned
about the impact of this chamfered edge
and the conflict with the crossing etc
taking the point raised by members about
banning them a no-smoking area typically
on this side
I think you might struggle to say oh you
can't smoke in X that was the general
public it's like what I was thinking of
it's not a place to suggest is if we had
a planning condition that said the
outside area we could hatch this on a
claim so the applicant could be clear
shall not be used for an outdoor display
congregating and activities associated
the user inside that would allow the
public to walk across it smoking which
could be unavoidable but anybody that
the applicants could manage that would
be going outside the staff could
supervise and so not in that area can
find it to that area if members are
happy with that we could we could mark
on this plan that that error is from any
use that would be more enforceable than
and would cover some of the other points
raised about drinkers sitting around and
gathering in groups you just say no-go
zone
and looking back on their own before
book which is in the troubled
interceptor gym it's really around that
smoking situation I think it's almost
impossible to impose a smoking condition
on anywhere on that four core it's
perfectly legal for anybody smoking to
smoking in the open open area it's not
inside a building I don't see how the
owners of the property would be able to
enforce I think when were talking about
conditions in general we do have to bear
in mind the point that you've made they
do have to be realistic and enforceable
I can remember that met many years ago
when right through the town the brass
studs were put in to clearly delineate
the areas that were in control of the
the properties because there was a
plethora of a board sanitizing boards
that people were chopping over so the
schemes evolved to make it clear what
was in the control of the parish
frontages clearly here that the brass
beds and as we've previously seen in the
in previous existence there was there
was all sorts of goods but outside so it
is an area directly in control of the
the shop or whatever the uses is put to
and we have to put things that are
realistic and effective and as you said
members of the public walking paths can
be can be smoking the the ability to
control someone that's whether there
visiting establishment orchid say that
just visited the establishment and just
stand outside so I think it is a really
a really really difficult one
so I if we took if we move to talk about
conditions we've got to have things that
are like strikes which is a lot clearer
than I could make it thank you
okay to a point we control the actions
of people so just for clarity would be a
condition be around
you dirty spot furniture and in a
hatched area rather than trying to take
what people doing so members we've got a
motion for approval with further
condition which will relate to the
hatching of the side area where the my
way just start to narrow towards the the
crossing they everyone clear about what
we're talking about here Jared I'm not
clear about the smoking situation so
someone said it these with regards to
furniture others are seven games dancer
smokey I can't see how you couldn't
impose a condition smoking
chairman if I might what what we can say
in a planning edition has to be precise
first of all it has to be within control
of the applicant now that that for court
premises sides of the stunts is under
the management supervision of the
proprietor the licensee so they can go
to reasonable lengths to encourage
people catch the signage in the window
please do not stand the Lloyds are in
this area they have staff on duty you
can supervise there is an outside area
that members on my reading of the debate
would be allowed freedom or congregation
an outside smoking I think members would
be picked up on the narrowness of the
pavement in the conflict at the junction
and the crossing now it's within the
applicants control if members put a
condition on to say this area so we
clearly marked the area on the approved
plan we had ship and we have a condition
this is within this area there shall be
no outside activity storage of furniture
or seating things like this be precise
as we can so that we make it as least
likely as possible that people will move
in a realm in our the condition won't
rule out you'll never see somebody
smoking or waiting there you could have
people waiting to going waiting for a
friend to arrive and they just have
happen to congregate on that corner but
if the the way the establishment runs
its business the knowledge of that
condition and how crucial it was to
members I would like to think that most
of the time the premises would operate a
good management philosophy to that area
to cease its attraction for the issues
that are concerning members and as like
other members have said from time to
time people don't do nothing to do the
premises no customers or patrons will
still hang around there waiting for
friends on mobile phones and smoke won't
stop that kind of thing what you will be
able to do by the
be able to control the intensity I would
have thought to a reasonable limit now I
think that is sounding in planning so we
can achieve that by carefully drafted
condition is that easier understanding
get away their chairman just have to
retrace where the studs are would the
applicant be within his rights
personally I think that would exacerbate
the problem of the narrowness of it we
should really do care but would he be
time to do it termination that's rusty
on the previous shots but that may be
possible I know they can do a thwart an
advertisement they can put that up there
in a certain way to create enclosure
what draft is right what the condition
will do from hippie structures and
things like that the point that was
raised earlier about furniture
associated with the woman he would read
something like within the area shown
hatched on plain whatever number it is
but the key is the area we hatched
there should be no furniture no pub
related activities think things like
this that we can try and limit trying to
foresee in the nimac kind of things that
happen from time to time but if members
felt with the success of that condition
you'd never see somebody smoking there
on a mobile phone ringing a friend or
something
whether they're patrons or not you can't
absolutely guarantee that it would be
forever free but what you would
hopefully achieve is that you wouldn't
have it used in common and over spilling
which was I think some other points
right because they don't really have an
area on new to the growth side and we
can say well that should be used in it
and if the management on-site understand
that
this is what this decision tonight
swings on then they'll know that there
be a condition that the enforcement
officers could enforce if they they
disrespect the condition and it causes
all sorts of problems hopefully spj i
think mr strannix is clearly understands
the intent of what members are trying to
achieve and he's described his scale in
language ability to contribute
that's why we're effectively describe
okay members Pauline form the confidence
in the tradition that has as strangers
get to describe those members in favor
of the approval as indicator please
please show your hands those games that
item is approved thank you very much
[Music]